but every time i get one home i get to
save another one but it seems like
george because when
when i was at your house that he was
really cool
good with people he was a weirdo no he
was still scared he's scared yeah he was
kind of like
what he was scared of men yeah excuse me
yep he was scared of the estrogen
testosterone
yeah he wasn't afraid of me i'm a man
did you just pretend you didn't hear me
hello hello um do you need a banana yeah
yeah
when you look at me you don't do let's
go back to me real quick okay
you look i'd like to go back to me real
quick and when you look at me honestly
do i not seem nailed to you can i can
you just stop and i'll answer it yeah
no can i ask the question i don't know
what it's gonna be but i know what your
question is
what is the question well here's the
thing i think the definition of
man quote unquote has changed and
masculine and i actually think now the
most masculine [ __ ] you can do
is be vulnerable and open and honest and
loyal
so i actually think that you are the
most masculine
[ __ ] in the game yeah but that
dog
was triggered and scared of like
traditionally
masculine like i actually andrew santino
[Laughter]
no i just mean like that brutish like um
aggression is like ultimately weakness
emotional weakness right at some point
so it's like i
think we conflate masculine with tough i
think we can play massive like it's just
the words don't mean anything anymore um
but i think that actually
like like like lex um um friedman went
on joe rogan the other day
uh and he's a ai like genius
guy he like does all the teslas and
stuff and he went on joe rogan's show
whose audience is
you know like a tough guy
got bro guys masculine guys
legends alleged alphas alphas whatever
these were alpha and alpha doesn't mean
alpha because the alpha
keeps and the alpha powerful people
don't need to show their power so it's
like
but let's just go with the traditional
socially constructed definitions which
was like
lex friedman goes on there and he reads
poetry
and joe was like what are you doing and
he was like i'm reading poetry about
love and it was like the most gangster
[ __ ]
i've ever seen just sweat wet
[ __ ] wet wow i was just like he's
pretty hot
yeah i like that he also has a very flat
affect when he speaks
yes so i don't know where he lands
really he is a robot yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
he's so um it's like this new
masculinity of like
are you checking your phone he's going
to see that lex friedman no no i i i'm
also um i'm talking but i'm saying like
that to me like that because
masculinity is about courage and bravery
and right now in this moment in time the
most courageous brave thing you can do
is say that hurt my feelings trees so
that is why joseph
go do it do it do it trees by joyce
kilmer yes
i think i shall but let me start over a
british accent
hello trees there we go by joyce kilmer
i think i shall never see a poem lovely
as a tray
a tree whose hungry mouth is pressed
against the sweet earth flowering breast
a tree that looks
like god all die and lifts her leafy
arms to pry
a tree that may in summer wear a nest of
robins
in her hair upon whose bosom
snow has led goose intimately
lives with ryan poems are made by fools
like may
but only god can make a try wet where is
your is your dick what what is your deck
wet so wet
yeah yeah exactly wait whitney are you
into femme boys
[Laughter]
uh what what are you saying
boys bts okay so this is gonna sound
fanboys like the guys who wear pearls
the guys who kind of like really
lean into their like feminine gait
um um
like like how harry styles now wears
pearl necklaces and blouses
more even more
they're not leading with this like gruff
kind of you know
i just want to be choked
if they use that pearl necklace to choke
and make another pearl necklace i'm fine
with it um i
i don't know the answer because i don't
think i've been in that situation like i
i'm always i surprise myself with the
times i get sexually attracted to people
and i'm like i never
i don't like when people like i have a
type no you don't like exactly not if
you're an awake
evolving person and you're growing and
changing every day and you're a
different person all the time
hormonally us chemically right yeah so
it's like there are
times that like a really muscular guy
with tattoos like is like
not attractive to me and their time it's
mental i don't know yeah
i never knew it would be difficult to
date for me why because i wouldn't date
you
it wouldn't be bad you know in a world
you know
that hurt that burned why didn't i have
to admit that
that burned a bit because i uh this oh
by the way what i never
you've known i've never talked about
like what happened when i started the
comedy store like what the guys were
saying
what do you mean because you were around
when i started listen
oh my god well you want to get there why
would this is a positive podcast
comedy store is a documentary is airing
like i watched it i went to the comedy
store two nights ago with andy letterman
and we watched it it was just like
so surreal to watch that and to think
that i was
once not all right let you do what i
mean